le chat de la Maison Blanche qui me
laisse la la Russie de forte sanction en
cas d'escalade avec l'Ukraine c'était
hier soir et il lui a demandé des
garanties sur le nom l'élargissement de
l'OTAN vers les le samedi du Kremlin a
dénoncé également l'accroissement du
potentiel militaire de l'Alliance
atlantique à la frontière ainsi que la
ligne destructrice de caisse on va voir
ça justement avec notre correspondant à
Moscou Antoine clairon
[Musique]
bonjour Antoine alors qu'est-ce qui
ressort de cette discussion hier entre
la dire Poutine Joe Bayonne
Olivier vient dans la soirée le Kremlin
publier un communiqué qui donne en
quelque sorte la vision russe de ces
échanges et comme prévu il avant tu
étais questions d'Ukraine la dire
Poutine n'accepte pas que la Russie soit
tenue pour responsable de l'escalade
détention sur place et pointe du doigt
des provocations de la part de Kiev et
l'activité importante de l'OTAN à ses
frontières le président russe a
également demandé à son homologue
américain des garanties écrite
concernant de mesure l'arrêt de
l'expansion de l'OTAN Verlet est l'arrêt
du déploiement de système offensif
d'armement dans le voisinage proche de
la Russie a conseillé de Vladimir
Poutine qui a suivi ces échanges d'hier
à tenue à mettre en perspective la
position de la Russie vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine en rappelant que Moscou occupé
que par sa propre sécurité
hier soir je transmets les paroles de
Poutine selon mon interprétation mais
elles sont très importante
putin a déclaré
vous les Américains est préoccupé par
nos bataillons sur le territoire russe
à des milliers de kilomètres des
États-Unis
alors que nous nous sommes vraiment plus
occupée par notre sécurité et par la
sécurité de la Russie dans un sens
global et à l'échelle mondiale
voilà comment Poutine à commenter la
situation à la fin de la rencontre
dans le bilan des échanges de vue sur le
tas
d'autres sujets comme l'Iran la
cybersécurité ou encore l'amélioration
du fonctionnement de l'ambassade
respectives et de façon plus général je
donne et bladimir Poutine se sont dit
conscients de leurs responsabilités
concernant la stabilité et le maintien
de la sécurité dans le monde si les
contacts vont se poursuivre entre groupe
de travail des 2 pays sur tous les
sujets abordés il y a 6 mois lors du
sommet de Genève
merci beaucoup Antoine pour toutes ces
précisions Antoine Cléro au franc direct
de notre couple ce matin